how can you get differentiated value
from your content to transform your
business first you need to manage the
content at any scale with security
mobility and collaboration throughout
its lifecycle IBM content foundation is
the market leading content management
platform your business can rely on to
reduce cost and risk on premise on cloud
or hybrid IBM content foundation is
mobile ready optimized scalable secure
social and collaborative join millions
of users who are addressing the needs of
the digital workplace and delivering
value with this solution start by
streamlining decision-making and
collaboration with document management
first select a document from the list
view you can see a thumbnail on the
right side of the screen so without
opening a document you can get an idea
of its contents use the filmstrip view
to browse visual documents like
PowerPoint presentations and image files
with role-based redaction companies can
set viewing controls on documents based
on need and access privileges depending
on the roles the user has they will only
be able to see what parts of the
document they have access to the
solution also comes with social
management features that track content
views as well as likes comments tags and
number of downloads to help measure
value of your published content
Enterprise Search provides an intuitive
way to find content quickly across
disparate silos select the magnifying
glass and choose your search criteria in
search view recent searches are
highlighted above team spaces are
private areas that group people searches
and documents for collaboration with the
select team the document review and
approval feature lets you launch review
workflows and easily run and track
approvals depending on your business
needs document review and approval can
be handled sequentially or
simultaneously content collaboration and
sharing is available anytime anywhere on
any device use quick actions to
at least start tasks in your work list
content Navigator provides access to IBM
content foundation assets directly from
Microsoft Office this lets you find edit
and store documents as well as launch
review and approve workflows without
leaving office applications using the
office online integration users can work
collaboratively to view and edit office
files online without a local office
application IBM content foundation makes
custom application development easy no
coding required create an entry template
by simply naming it and setting
permissions select a document type and
edit the layout you can add a tabbed
layout with customized properties on
each tab to enhance the users experience
test templates easily this enhances your
ability to deliver customized solutions
that expedite information sharing roll
out a corporate approved user experience
in hours instead of months seamlessly
integrate content into line of business
applications and support high scale
business transactions and become a
data-driven enterprise where everyone
has the same trusted view and makes
faster better decisions all with IBM
content foundation for more information
on IBM content foundation including
additional capabilities like role based
redaction and office online integration
visit ibm.com or contact your IBM
representative